elon musk
seems
sad to me to see but seems to have a
non-zero
non-empty set of uh doubters
in this world and yeah you could you
could say maybe
it's because of financial because of
shorting stocks and all those kinds of
things but i know people that don't
aren't shorting the stock and they're
still
full of doubt
first of all to me as a human being that
breaks my heart i think
optimism is just fun
and also optimism is the thing that
creates the change so
but when i talked about them i think the
more interesting doubt is elon musk's
own self-doubt
and
the the doubt from people that are in
like
in the field of battle so these aren't
just critics but you know the legit
engineers that doubt whether something
is possible when there's all that kind
of doubt like you have with starship now
like you had when building autopilot
from scratch throughout the history of
autopilot what do you do
and that's when you said [ __ ] that we'll
get it done i don't care about optimism
or pessimism [ __ ] that we'll get it done
i mean i'm gonna i don't know i feel
like i'm gonna take that little clip and
just like play it every morning for
myself because you can get so lost into
overthinking stuff the reality is just
get it done and never don't quit until
it's done that's it simple
you